well in the news this week I've heard
these stories of this guy
how many Cola would should handle who's
been apparently trying to make a small
nuclear reactor in his kitchen yeah I
think it was in Sweden in his kitchen on
his oven top by the looks of it and
there's a picture here where things have
gone a bit wrong and everything's blown
up all over the place well I've only
just found out about this so I've just
been looking it up now and out but
according to this bloke here he was
mixing americium radium beryllium in 96%
sulfuric acid which he doesn't sound
like a very nice mixture I have to say I
think what he was trying to do was use
that mixture to mix them more
efficiently so that he had a mixture of
these compounds that he could then use
in this sort of so-called nuclear
reactor that he was trying to construct
what I can gather is that what he was
trying to do was to split atoms which is
nuclear fission so that's basically take
the atomic core and you split it up into
more than one part well there's a bit of
me wonders why he's trying to do this
because actually this happens in nature
all the time radioactivity is a part of
nature I'm not really sure why
specifically he wanted to do with these
particular elements and what he was
actually aiming to get what I do know is
it looks kind of dangerous from the
results on top of his cooker thing about
dangerous it really comes down to how
much of a particular material or
chemical compound that you actually have
now from what I've managed to pick up he
said that when he scanned the area with
his detector he couldn't actually pick
up any radioactivity which would imply
that he actually had very small
quantities nevertheless it's really not
a good idea to have chemicals like this
not in a laboratory setting because they
could have ended up and you know going
down the sink and getting into the water
he's done quite a bit of homework I have
to say if we if we score
he's got some items here about uranium
and he talks about the different
isotopes and how only certain isotopes
are usable for the nuclear industry for
fission and he mentions thorium and he
also mentions aluminium William a little
bit further down
we've got radium and he talks about
ammonium and how it's used in smoke
detectors which most households have so
we've all got very small quantities of
Hamoui sium in our and houses I think
what he was trying to do was use the
americium to supply a stream of neutrons
and that these neutrons would bash up
whichever atom he had in mind and break
it up and cause the fission but I can't
be sure which ones he was actually
targeting
well I think he's got in trouble because
you're not really supposed to have
chemicals like this in a normal
household setting it's one thing to
handle them in a laboratory but like I
say if you've got them in a house they
could get into wastewater streams going
out for the general public could be
exposed to these and actually hello the
actual quantities may not be large it's
not really the point you can't just have
everybody using all of these chemicals
as the Y's the whole landscape would end
up covered with them so that's why he's
in trouble I think but why should
science be restricted to scientists
maybe he was going to find some amazing
breakthrough is no chance he'll make a
great breakthrough there's always a
chance but you've got to do these things
safely you know your conscious run away
with a great idea it's it's all fine and
well if you get a fantastic result but
if you kill yourself in the process
while I think you've defeated your own
objectives really
[Music]
as far as I know if you split atoms
that's really dangerous is it a chance
that he would blow up a whole city or
something I don't think so because of
the scale and I think he was working out
like I said if he couldn't detect these
compounds above background he clearly
can't have been working with very much
and you actually need quite reasonable
often kilogram quantities of these sorts
of elements to even begin to start
constructing bombs and even then you've
really got to know what you're doing to
make them work I'll have to say I'm
quite it's quite surprising to hear that
compounds like this can be bought on
eBay although what I have to say is if
they are out there on eBay I'd be quite
interested to know just how pure they
really are you're skeptical
I'm a little bit skeptical but I'm a
scientist we're always skeptical
well I have to say I do I admire his
drive of curiosity but it's absolutely
not something that I would recommend
that you do in your own home why just
because I think the danger outweighs the
benefit and at the end of the day if you
end up injuring yourself it's just not
worth it this is why we have all these
levels of safety and training and
science to ensure that we can do our
research safely